let's do it welcome to lost in  translation where we are now officially  a series  we take a recipe we put it through  google translate to give us a really  hilariously translated recipe step one  bring it to josh who could josh possibly  be  i must find the truth no  is it like a haiku retire alaska from  the oven  eight ounces of i know  i don't know not today not ever add some  isotopes wow you're doing things weird i  think it's air freshener  i can't get through i can't get through  if only a friend could save me no one's  gonna save you no one's gonna say  time to call mimo please help me traffic  jam  mashed potatoes do you normally mash  your potatoes before cooking them  this is like taking a spanish vinyl i  failed  [Music]  you